personalmente si voy a referirme a mí
mismo diré que soy una persona así -ha
pero pueden decir lo que quieran me da
igual
spectrum temporada cuatro episodio 7
autismo invitamos a 7 personas con
autismo para ver el rango de sus valores
y creencias me llamo jej tengo 19 años
fue diagnosticado tarde con autismo no
hay forma de parecer autista ya que es
un espectro muy amplio soy yo saya tengo
18 años al principio estaba muy inseguro
porque sonaba como algo malo pero empecé
a darme cuenta de que el autismo se
parece más a mí que a una enfermedad me
llamo jane atrasen tengo 23 años el
autismo es más común de lo que las
personas creen y solo si podemos hacer
que el mundo sea más consciente y
aceptable sería más fácil para todos soy
christopher carol tengo 38 años me gusta
actuar no está eso relacionado con el
autismo muy bien soy yo ni tengo 19 años
y soy un artista en todas las áreas
estoy realmente orgulloso de tener
autismo me hace ver el mundo de forma
diferente mi nombre es yo
el hecho de que me comunique de forma
diferente no significa que no lo
entienda me llamo vela tengo 22 años en
la secundaria no podía hablar realmente
así que yo era del tipo no verbal ahora
tengo más confianza en mí misma y soy
capaz de hablar con otras personas
[Música]
considero el término especial
ofensivo
321 ya muy en desacuerdo desacuerdo
algún desacuerdo algo de acuerdo de
acuerdo muy de acuerdo
a mí me parece que
es una etiqueta un poco mala decir que
una persona es especial
es indicar que es muy diferente para
funcionar
al igual que cuando actuó en los
espectáculos en los que he estado las
personas empiezan a susurrar entre el
público y a susurrar entre ellos esa
persona era especial o no y eso
es un poco duro para mi especial puede
usarse como algo bueno pero también
puede usarse en situaciones como hay
porque no sales con ellos hay porque son
especiales como ya saben somos los otros
somos menos que no somos menos solo
somos diferentes siento que puedo hacer
que las personas neuróticas se sientan
un poco mejor y realmente suena más
agradable para ellos pero creo que es
más ofensiva digo si tú la usas con ese
tipo de tono e inflexión cuando pienso
en especial al hablar del autismo pienso
en educación especial y no lo entiendo
porque es especial tener algunas
adaptaciones adicionales o aprender de
una manera diferente no es educación
especial es educación de apoyo extra
estoy de acuerdo en que la palabra
especial puede significar cualquier cosa
es solo la forma en que se usa y no creo
que sea justo
todos somos especiales
me gusta eso sí sí sí tengo problemas
para hacer amigos
me cuesta hacer amigos porque soy del
tipo no verbal
si realmente no hice amigos hasta que
empecé la universidad porque no estaba
en muchas actividades y esas cosas
siempre quise estar sola y siempre me
resultó difícil hablar con las personas
durante mucho tiempo especialmente
cuando estaba en la primaria me costó un
poco hacer amigos por eso estuve solo
durante un tiempo
hasta que hasta hasta que llegué a la
secundaria fui a una escuela privada
cuyo objetivo era básicamente
crear una comunidad que trataba de
encontrar amigos y cosas por el estilo
así que por eso estoy parado en algo de
desacuerdo porque ahora tengo muchos
amigos pero
pensándolo bien cuando se trata de la
primaria la pasé muy mal yo sinceramente
no tengo problemas para hacer amigos
hablo con todos los que conozco y con
todos los que conozco me hago amigo y no
se me salen naturalmente solo digo oye
seamos amigos y ellos dicen sí y sucede
cuando conoces a alguien por primera vez
yo soy buena hablando pero a largo plazo
se vuelve demasiado complicado
simplemente es que me doy cuenta que no
me gustan muchas personas y que
posiblemente yo tampoco le guste a ellas
así que estoy un poco de acuerdo sí
bueno supongo que para mí y también
tengo ansiedad social así que nunca ha
sido fácil para mí hacer amigos pero a
veces me siento mejor estando solo y
haciendo mis cosas y cuando uno sale y
conoce a personas nuevas hay que
esforzarse mucho para saber qué decir
saber que no hacer y no auto estimularse
y esas cosas por eso es más difícil
salir y tener toda esa energía mental
puesta en eso cuando puedes ser tú mismo
y por ti mismo pero si tengo amigos por
eso estoy aquí y no hay excelente
tengo un problema similar cuando era más
joven tenía fobia social
pasé gran parte de mi infancia viviendo
o jugando dentro de mi propia cabeza lo
que no me ayudó precisamente con la
habilidad de socializar si puede
desencadenar una crisis con la que no
quieres llíria problemas sensoriales
exacto
si estaba diciendo que así me siento si
ser diagnosticado con autismo me ayudó a
entenderme más
321 ya
bueno por años y años me preguntaba por
qué la música en el auto está tan alta
porque me hace tanto daño porque no
puedo hacer amigos fácilmente porque no
capto el sarcasmo siento que me ayudó a
entenderme a mí mismo porque dejé de
sentirme tan mal
mi cuerpo y mi cerebro a veces trabajan
en contra del otro
cuando yo leí por primera vez los como
les dicen no son síntomas criterios como
criterios y los criterios para el
autismo fue algo alucinante porque ni
siquiera sabía que existía o que se
podía poner en palabras como he dicho
antes pensaba que todo el mundo lidiaba
con eso y lo ocultaba he recurrido mucho
más al amor propio desde que me enteré
de mi diagnóstico hace dos años eso ha
sido probablemente lo más liberador que
he hecho por mí de hecho solía tener
crisis diarias me enfadaba mucho y nadie
sabía porque si unas pequeñas pero
pueden hacer que una explora me di
cuenta de que después de que me
diagnosticaron el autismo todo el mundo
a mi alrededor se dio cuenta de que
estaba menos enfadado y que mis crisis
eran menores porque empiezas a saber
cómo prevenirlas empiezas a saber que te
hace entrar en crisis bueno creo que
estoy algo en desacuerdo porque en
realidad no he sido diagnosticado nadie
me ha hecho la prueba del autismo así
que en que nos basamos simplemente en lo
que diga un médico un día cualquiera
qué fue lo que te hizo venir hoy
algunos médicos han dicho que tengo
autismo aunque al menos el doble de
médicos que he conocido han dicho que no
lo tengo así es eso eso es lo que crees
o simplemente a ritmo de ahora
opino que si tengo autismo por una parte
pero no puedo decir que esté de acuerdo
con el diagnóstico piensas hacerte uno
en el futuro no conozco a nadie que me
haga uno si es un gran problema en
realidad son muy caros y muy difíciles
de conseguir eso hicieron un calvario yo
recibí uno de mi psiquiatra porque ya
estaba bajo su cuidado si eso realmente
me ayudó sobre todo a encontrar una ruta
diferente con la educación tenía un
problema con las matemáticas y los
números ahora después de que me
diagnosticaron y estoy yendo a la
escuela que ayuda con el autismo
generalmente ahora estoy haciendo
estadísticas me ayudó mucho me ayudó a
entender cómo funciona mi cerebro y cómo
puedo obtener ayuda y cómo sé que mi
cerebro funciona de manera diferente veo
el mundo en un aspecto más creativo
pienso fuera de la caja y estoy aquí
estoy en una galaxia las formas están a
mi alrededor yo estoy fuera de todas
ellas me molesta cuando las personas me
compadecen
321 ya
y yo aquí se compadecen de mí por muchas
cosas porque también tengo múltiples
enfermedades mentales y condiciones
médicas cuando le cuento a las personas
todas dicen cómo puedes ser feliz tu
vida parece difícil y yo les digo es lo
que conozco no tiene que ser el fin de
mi mundo no me gusta que me compadezcan
por las cosas que tengo sólo porque soy
discapacitado no significa que mi vida
sea una miseria por eso si solo he dicho
que estoy algo en desacuerdo porque
crecí realmente obsesionada con
enmascarar me y creo que en mi caso es
lo contrario porque las personas tienen
muchas expectativas de mí yo puedo
enmascarar mi presentarme y por eso
muchas personas olvidan que soy autista
y se olvidan de las necesidades que
puedo tener y olvidan de pronto la
paciencia que deben tener y yo no sé
hasta qué punto me pueden compadecer
e incluso he tenido terapeutas que
intentan enseñarme que no soy autista
tengo que enseñarles sobre ello y luego
me dicen que no esto es muy frustrante
porque yo
contra el micrófono
no puedo cambiar mi forma de ser así que
en lugar de compadecer me quiero que las
personas intenten comprenderme y
aceptarme tal y como soy
también es que no me compadezcan pero
que estén conmigo estén conmigo en el
momento no se sientan mal por mí como si
ustedes pudieran tratarme como si fuera
como si yo fuera una persona normal
mientras crecía las personas solían
animarme ahora
con 22 años miro atrás y pienso que
deberían haberme tratado como una niña
normal porque cuando las personas te
miman puede ser un obstáculo para una
vida también eso puede ser otro peso
añadido que no me hace sentir que no
puedo ser yo misma si solía tener ese
problema con muchas personas decían
cosas como oye está bien todos somos un
poco autistas o algo así y es como no yo
odio tanto ese comentario lo recibo
tantas veces también odio sex ordinario
no todos somos autistas el hecho de que
te identifiques con un par de cosas de
los rasgos no significa que seas autista
necesaria exactamente tienes que tener
más de tres cosas sabes si sólo estás
siendo una persona porque te relacionas
con otros si eres humano preferiría no
tener
autismo
321 ya
estoy muy en desacuerdo porque si no
tuviera autismo no sería exactamente la
misma persona es parte de mi identidad
sería realmente la misma persona si no
tuviera autismo pero creo que tengo que
quedarme solo en algo porque en realidad
no me han diagnosticado
autismo otra cosa que
otro de los problemas son las luchas que
suelo tener por ser una persona con
autismo es que encuentro día a día que
tienen que ver con el hecho de que vive
en un mundo neuro típico y no porque yo
tenga autismo si es que eso tiene
sentido así que yo preferiría vivir en
un mundo más consciente del autismo o en
un mundo menos neurótico
creo que eso sería lo ideal no cambiarme
a mí misma por ser autista solo eso
puede que tenga autismo pero eso me hace
ser quien soy y no lo cambiaría si
pudiera elegir
y los pienso igual por eso prefiero el
lenguaje que da prioridad al diagnóstico
como persona autista y personas con
autismo porque personalmente mi autismo
me define no es sólo una parte de mi mi
diabetes es una parte de mí el hecho de
que mi páncreas haya dejado de funcionar
no afecta mi forma de actuar o de ser
pero mi autismo afecta mi forma de ver
el mundo mi forma de procesar mi forma
de sentir las cosas mi forma de actuar y
socializar y a pesar de que no me gusta
todo de mí no creo que el hecho de no
ser autista me haga quererme de repente
creo que solo se trata del hecho de que
necesito trabajar para aceptarme más en
general y por eso siento que prefiero
tener mi autismo porque me ha hecho ser
yo sí
yo diría que soy una persona con autismo
pero también me da igual
como las personas lo usen recuerdo que
cuando empezaron a decir persona autista
en vez de persona con autismo me quedé
como o muy bien no me importa así que si
tengo que elegir me llamen ni cómo sea
pero si tuviera que elegir personal si
voy a referirme a mí mismo diré que soy
una persona autista pero pueden decir lo
que quieren me da igual para mí yo lo
veo como una comunidad neurótica
tratando de ser siempre agradable como
es posible y no sé simplemente no
escuchado una persona autista en lo que
estoy por ello realmente siempre escucho
a las personas neuróticas que lo hacen
me siento conectado con otras personas
del espectro
321 ya
y aquí
bueno estoy de acuerdo porque a algunas
personas les pasa exactamente lo mismo
que a mí pero también estoy un poco en
desacuerdo porque hay personas que
tienen un funcionamiento más alto o uno
más bajo así que es difícil
conectar con la gente que es no sé cómo
decirlo lo entiendo así lo entiendo como
son tan diferentes supongo puede ser más
difícil conectar en cierto grado puede
que no todos pasemos por lo mismo pero
con una etiqueta como el autismo creo
que todos todos podemos conectar con eso
así es como me siento con esa etiqueta
hay un buen sentido de comunidad sí
estoy de acuerdo aunque tengamos
dice diferentes historias de autismo yo
creo que creo que podemos
relacionarnos entre nosotros y todavía
y tener diferentes perspectivas y
exactamente porque siento que
especialmente ahora nos separamos porque
tenemos miedo de decir que somos
autistas pero creo que tenemos
tenemos que empezar a acercarnos y
entonces educar a las personas y en un
dado un aumento de las comunidades en
línea son el inti por la neuro
diversidad y esas cosas cuando cuando me
enteré fue genial poder profundizar en
el internet y encontrar todas estas
perspectivas de autistas cuando pude
conectarme con ellos en línea luego
cuando tuve que volver a la vida real
ellos por más que intentáramos hablar y
eso me sentía aislada de nuevo porque
siento que aunque sean personas
neuróticas o autistas de todas formas me
voy a sentir alienada y por eso dejé de
intentarlo con el tiempo ayuda cuando no
tienes que dar explicaciones a los demás
y puedes relajarte y pasar el rato sin
que te juzguen
y sinceramente
gracias muy bien chicos terminamos
[Risas]
quieren que pongamos nuestras manos y
digamos autista
realmente vamos a hacer esto
bueno listos
[Risas]
jubilee se empático